qu'est-ce qu'il y a tu as entendu
frapper
moi
[Musique]
on parle dans mon village
d'un être maléfique qui entre les
montagnes alentours
maléfique il prend l'apparence d'un
homme pour dissimuler sa véritable
nature et la nuit il se nourrit du sang
des innocents je savais que les anciens
c'est des marchés
pour faire que les nôtres soient
épargnés et vous avez été livré à cet
homme ce n'est pas un homme c'est un
animal non ce n'est pas non plus une
créature stupide surtout ne faites pas
cette erreur
nous le nommons Dracula et vous pensez
qu'il vous a qu'il vous a amené à bord
[Musique]
il m'a amené avec lui pour se nourrir
il est ici Monsieur clémence
la chose qui porte la peau d'un homme
[Musique]
la nuit il boit notre sang il est sur le
bateau
et personne n'aurait jamais